Allemagne
- France
le 13 décembre 1997 à Deauville la
famille Thalmann au complet était la
mille francs par personne oui spectacle
comment vous appelez-vous sophie dans la
vie
prendre ma place oui j'aimerais bien
Le Rebelle
merci bien ça s'appelle ça fait quoi
d'être Miss France l'envers du diadème
c'est chez Michel Lafon tout te raconter
c'est des nuages vous ai prises durant
l'année vous étiez Miss France sur votre
vie de Miss un espèce de de journal
intime raconter tout même les heures de
Fontenay
et
donc en fait on découvre les bouquins
c'est que toutes vos apparition sont
gérés par Madame de Fontenay son fils
Xavier qui touche un pourcentage en fait
au salon de la Porte de Versailles
pendant une semaine
c'est vraiment le rituel quoi et
voilà
[Musique]
et
c'est
comme ça
les photos dédicacées les bisous et les
mains baladeuses
parce que temps en temps comme ça et tu
vois la
Coupe du monde
[Musique]
tout va bien
pour présenter le charme et l'élégance
de la beauté française c'est comme ça
que ça s'appelle je viens contrat
un contrat en une semaine avant de
participer au concours il y a la photo
pour Télé 7 Jours avec toutes les
candidates la fameuse photo est toujours
là on nous trois on prend nos
mensurations et tout ça et à la fin on
apprend que c'est le fameux contrat et
on a pas de double et comme moi j'étais
loin d'imaginer que j'allais j'allais
gagner je l'ai pas vrai véritablement vu
et
je pensais tellement gagné et j'ai pas
de double
je vous envoie tout ça enfin ça te dit
de faire
un
hôtel en face de la gare
et vous dit du pain donc il était dur de
donner l'âge de
mais non elle me connaît
parce que d'abord j'étais très attaché à
Sophie du fait qu'elle était Lorraine
comme moi que j'ai que je l'ai encouragé
la première année la vérité que dauphine
de Miss Lorraine je lui écris pour lui
dire ou pas vous décourager il faut
revenir et revenir après on a passé une
merveilleuse comme toutes les Miss
France aller chercher des choses comme
ça
j'en ai pris c'est dur
parce que je pense que
je dis je dis également que j'ai même
dit que j'étais désolée d'être seul
parce que ça prend faire germer dans un
lit baldaquin
sur un grave problème vraiment je crois
que c'est un truc là
on
peut dire tout de suite c'est que non
c'est vrai c'est lui
je veux ce soir régler cette histoire
donc je vous ai jamais bien entendu et
Xavier pour ça c'est pas ça arrive c'est
pas ça on fera pas d'histoires et Xavier
bien entendu il y a des Miss et que vous
êtes bien entendu ce qui est bien
entendu pour ça
vous êtes un petit peu ridiculisé dans
le livre c'est un petit peu présente le
second madame de Fontenay
prendre un petit peu la tête qui était
normal parce que j'avoue que pendant 1
ans madame de Fontenay à jouer ma maman
et ça tout à fait normal qu'on qu'on a
des petits des accroches si c'est vrai
qu'avec Xavier ce qui me demander de
faire monter des Papes
c'est pas être suffisamment humain et de
déjà c'était la Thalmann la 1198 c'était
jamais Sophie on était vraiment une
étiquette la au début
particulier j'ai signé un contrat. Une
semaine une semaine avant
et je n'ai plus jamais mais
je crois que
faut déjà un peu de toi
mets sur 335 jours une fois il m'est
arrivé d'aller rendre service à
quelqu'un c'est tout
c'était où ça
donc j'ai pas besoin et encore moi
cinéma sultan pour ce pour les pour que
pour les autres Miss France
2 fois alors si vous avez toute l'année
vous avez fait l'encyclopédie un bouquin
et
pourquoi ne pas lui porter ses bagages
pourquoi la laisser toute seule
physiquement
alors vous avez pas le temps de manger
autre chose à faire malheureusement
caméra vous débarque à la gare là il
viendra
non mais c'est de la se déteste c'est
moi je suis content parce que moi je
pense qu'on peut la réconcilier avec
Geneviève
c'est vrai que j'aime bien vous dit vous
en parlant de votre mère elle vit dans
un monde de Mickey
tout le monde
oui non je pense que c'est tout
alors à mon avis elle a pas couché avec
raconter le même c'est vrai ou faux
je sais pas ce que je trouve étonnant
c'est qu'elle me déteste le premier jour
qu'on est un peu bizarre on se
connaissait pas avant
c'est ce livre au lieu de t'appeler que
ça va être Miss France ça serait plutôt
du s'appelait comment flinguer Xavier de
Fontenay il y a des gens derrière vous
qui
est devenu votre argent pas de partie
bien sûr
il a pris dans l'émission de Bernard
Tapie et j'avoue aussi que ça m'a fait
mal au cœur et après
avec
une nuit sur moi
naïve dit la vérité ici
j'ai pas besoin de ça pour être dans la
plénitude merci merci
merci
il est blessé
toujours téléphone encore plus plus ou
moins qu'avant et la radio aussi en
parallèle de problème on vous demande
quand on est Miss France de pas vous
afficher avec des garçons mais vous vous
dites c'est quand même pas le temps
d'avoir une aventure
à la Mecque
excitant Fabrice
je vais bien les mecs un peu plus âgé de
50 ans non j'ai
besoin
un homme qui a déjà bien vécu
[Musique]